[Music]
all right there
they are all the way up to number 13.
now we've talked through cousins at 16.
matt ryan 15 derek carr 14 baker
mayfield 13. let's start with matt ron
number seven last year in your preseason
rankings fell out of the top ten
sources tell me he was at number 11 in
your in-season adjustment yeah right now
he's down to number 15. explain yourself
chris well there's three though some
players that jumped him and had good
years we had some rookies that came into
the league who were real good you know
the guys that we just talked about there
right there you know derek carr and
mayfield i got hit them jumping him from
what i saw from last year yeah matt ryan
a year older still really good i don't
want to like take that away from him a
guy that you know again i'll make the
statement you can win a super bowl with
matt ryan there's no doubt you know he's
more than a system quarterback no you
can be you can be up 20. you could be
half 28 to three yes right yes well you
know also listen he can deserve some of
the blame there but i i do like think
that their defense could have helped out
a little too but you know again there's
a lot of positive things matt ryan can
do yeah does he need a system to a
degree sure but man you know for a guy
that's not super super athletic and
everything like that man he makes a lot
of plays outside of the system he's
still an incredible thrower in the 10 to
20 yard range you know when you break
him down he's so accurate great decision
makers that way and then even for your
prototypical pocket type quarterback the
one thing that always jumps out to me
when i go back and watch these guys to
do these rankings man he moves a lot
better than you you remember or give him
credit for makes a lot of nice plays
scrambling for five or just getting out
of the harm's way to get a completion
down the field and doing those type of
things you know so he is a good athlete
not a great athlete he's not going to do
a lot of scrambling and things like that
but you know overall still playing at a
high level and i think you know good
enough that's why you don't draft a
quarterback at number four this year for
atlanta because we got a few more years
left of matt ryan playing high level
football at the quarterback position
arthur smith one of the key ingredients
in the turnaround of ryan tannehill who
was never an mvp candidate before arthur
smith got his hands on him i think smith
recognized early on
hey i can win with matt ryan right i got
multiple years left remember there was
the the conflicting reports
in march i think before arthur blank
decided to get everyone on the same page
frankly that terry fontenot wanted to
think about a quarterback at number four
arthur smith wanted to stick with matt
ryan for multiple years they worked that
out quickly right and i was told at the
time there was never much of a dispute
that those reports were overblown but
you know it may have been a trial
balloon to see how people reacted to it
the bottom line is arthur smith's on
board with matt ryan and he's going to
be the guy and uh
you know even though he's down to 15
he's one year away from getting back
into the top ten even with julio jones
gone right kyle pitts hell of a weapon
calvin ridley ready to step up and be
the number one guy they got you know and
and it's we we get so caught up in
focusing on a team's offense
how good a team's defense is has a major
impact on how well the offense performs
sure how many red zone opportunities you
have how many you know how many
occasions you're pinned in your own end
or or you you just you know
yeah it's how you are because you're
down 14 points in the second quarter and
the the opposing defense is teeing off
on you already and disrupting your
ability to do what you want to do
because you become one-dimensional right
there's so many things that go into it
and that falcons defense just hasn't
been very good the last few years they
definitely not and the offenses had its
inconsistent moments too of just you
know oh hey we jump out on a lead
against this team and then we you know
disappear for two quarters or you know
we disappeared at the start of the game
and now we're down 20 to nothing and now
we march back and make it a football
game you know to me you know that that's
the interesting thing about matt ryan a
little bit of the negative i think is
where you i go that way too because
you're right like it's the team hasn't
been great they've had injuries you know
his stats i think of also to a degree
somewhat benefited from that too because
he has more yards and and things like
that that came in garbage time you know
and and the game the competitive part of
the game was over and then you start to
go whoa here look at all these big plays
it'll be a big year for matt ryan's
phenomenon what's that
the blake bortles phenol well yeah a
little a little but like the thing that
you know is going to be interesting
would you bring up with arthur smith is
hey that's been a down the field you
know big play
type of throw offense with ryan
tannehill who's been one of the best
deep ball throwers in football if not
the best the last two years
matt ryan
deep ball is one of the reasons i think
he's falling down the list for me a
little bit explosive throws
game-changing throws there are some
yards left on the field at times where
you go hey this guy's gone 70-yard
touchdown if he just throws it on the
money oh we had a slow down it was a
40-yard completion oh they kicked a
field goal that should have been a
touchdown there's definitely some of
that you know or balls that just don't
get there because they don't have quite
the heat and pace on it that you would
like that way but i think that to me
is where he fell off a little bit too
you know just unable to
maybe
uh just carry the team or assert his
presence the right way when wait things
aren't going good right now and we need
somebody to make a play or do something
for us to jump start us and that's where
i think some of the guys in front of him
have been a little bit better especially
the last year and going forward than
where matt ryan was
i'm gonna even more credit than that
because i think he has suffered from a
bad supporting cast no running back
that's true no doubt has been bad and i
think that that when you do your
in-season evaluation this year he's
going to be higher
than than number 15. maybe all the way
this is i don't i don't i don't disagree
with that this is a these these numbers
we're talking about 15 through a 10 or
11. holy i mean this is the hardest part
of my rankings these are really good
quarterbacks that you know you get
you're starting to get nitpicky with i'm
talking about a guy matt ryan who's you
know really awesome but i give yeah
derek carr and baker mayfield as we'll
dive into that the advantage of that
over him right now because of you know a
few my new things that we'll we'll
discuss here in a few minutes but still
really good let's talk let's yeah let's
talk about derek carr let's do it
because you haven't number 14 yeah which
which hopefully is enough to get derek
carr to unblock the pft twitter account
there's some respect derek you're at
number 14 baby yeah sims did the list
but i'll take credit for the stuff that
people like i'll take no credit or blame
for the things people don't like
including number 10 but that's still to
come derek carr at number 14
uh what is it that you saw that caused
you to bump him up from number nine well
i mean he
played the game
efficient as hell last year i mean made
a lot of plays and my biggest knock on
derek carr going into last year if you
can remember was just like hey let it
loose let it fly stop being so careful
with the ball you know force the ball
into a few windows you know don't don't
just lay the ball out there in the
middle of the field and go wait i just
want a completion no let it rip and get
a 70 yard touchdown like we're talking
about that's what i saw more of from
derek carr last year you know so there
was that aspect and then you know
play-making ability like that right
there listen that's the one thing that
jumped out to me more than anything
subtle movements in the pocket and
throwing under pressure from different
platforms
is
much better than i remember or expected
when i went back and studied him you
know he does have the ability to throw
the ball sidearm do those type of things
and he is a pretty damn good athlete you
know he's not going to run down the
sidelines for a 40-yard game but makes a
lot of great moves in the pocket can get
outside of the pocket i think really
understands the game now he's accurate
as hell you know there's not a lot not
to like from derek carr and the way he's
playing other than i would go you could
still be more aggressive you could still
let it fly a little bit more and
help your team out because you have the
talent to do that type of stuff
yeah look i i agree with you we talked
yesterday about derek carr the fact that
he had his best statistical season by
almost every factor last year he's got
to the point where he's he's mastered
the offense he can drive the ferrari
that's what he always said about the
john gruden offense he wants you to
drive the ferrari without scratching it
minimal scratches on the ferrari last
year and and this gets back to what we
discussed earlier this is the year this
is it up or out i don't know
for car it's more up or out than it is
gruden because i think that
if they fail to get to the playoffs this
year
there will be increased pressure on
gruden to get a different quarterback
next year i i think there will be and
they're gonna have to make a decision
because next year's the last year derek
carr's contract and i i don't i don't
he doesn't have to have a new contract
if he stays but i just think that after
this season is a good time
to make some sort of a decision yeah are
we
going to renew our vows with derek carr
or are we going to move on because
because
aaron rodgers
still out there potentially and the
raiders on his wish list
russell wilson raiders on his wish list
deshaun watson
potentially
raiders on his wish list so there will
be options for upgrades guys who we have
we have yet to unveil yeah on this show
right this year
that are out there that would be
upgrades for the raiders i think that
that's a fair question and this this is
the year
it's it's more important for derek carr
than john gruden to get to the playoffs
this year i firmly believe that yeah
it's i mean it's a solid point it's
certainly something to think about there
if he plays the way he did last year and
even a little bit better man i'd have a
hard time trading them for anything you
know especially like we talked about
with gruden and the fact that he's wired
we like
he took a step to me this year not only
in like the mastering of the offense
like we're talking about but his
attitude too you know i go back and
don't play this tape yet guys but like
that kansas city game i can still
remember the second game they beat
kansas city in kansas city now it's the
sunday night football game i can
remember the first series of the game
they drove down it was all on his plate
they got down close to the red zone
kansas city did something a little
different and it kind of like messed up
the robot for a second they had a call
timeout and i remember him coming off
the sideline looking at gruden and
gruden was like kind of like he's like
yup i got it yeah they fooled me i got
it
the rest of the game he was on point and
really gave them issues and here let's
play some of these clips kristen so you
can just hurry
he's all over everything that's the
thing i jump out it jumps out to me of
course you know i know this offense and
mentally
you know just always the right things
not that these are checks or anything
like that but you could see there's
comfort controlling the offense you know
little
linda you got to go 50 linda you gotta
go 50 all over pass protections hey
linda means go to the guy to the left i
put the guy in the middle let's linda
and go to 50. o-line get that right bam
gets the right protection now it's a
touchdown pass there's just so much of
that and there's a lot on his plate uh
more than i think people realize and he
did a really good job with it let alone
his physical play i thought was close to
special last year with some of the stuff
he did in a lot of games
so what does he have to do this year
what what do you expect from him well
like just like you said for matt ryan
and all that first off like their
defense needs to help out a little bit
that's for sure and these wide receivers
got to like come to the party and show
up finally here too like henry ruggs
like the honeymoon's over we got we got
guys that were drafted after you and in
the second round who way outperformed
you so i i look at derek carr to just go
just continue what you're doing
hopefully the guys around you can get
better and if there's just that one
thing i would say is just yeah he can
still be more aggressive that's the one
thing that i came away with to just go
when i watched film there was still a
handful of throws a few throws every
game where i'd go ah just let that rip
you got him like you're too talented to
turn that down and throw the five yard
shallow cross instead and some of that
and i i think that's the the biggest
thing that jumps out to me
well hey uh the the table is set and
we'll see they'll have a full stadium of
fans this year it's going to be a
happening and they get started week one
on monday night football with the ravens
coming to town so a stiff test yeah for
derek carr right out of the gates 13.
one of the ravens arch rivals in
cleveland their quarterback baker
mayfield first overall pick in 2018 on
the verge of becoming a superstar i
thought maybe it'd happen a little
higher i know chris
uh
why 13 for baker mayfield because
there's there's
so many there's good quarterbacks i mean
you'll see the top ten it's it's hard i
you know i when you see the top ten tell
me who you want me to kick out to put
baker mayfield listen i know
he's a top ten quarterback he's a top 10
quarterback he's a top 10 quarterback
you got 20 top 10 quarters i know when
it's time to list him it gets difficult
it gets difficult 100
and it was tough but man unbelievable
leap i mean what a year he had last year
and i think like the one thing that just
comes to my mind with baker mayfield
grip it and rip it man there are so many
like high level aggressive
down field throws that baker mayfield
made all year long especially the second
half of the year you know the first half
of the year was good he was kind of
learning his way in the offense the
second part of the year he started to
carry the offense just as much as it
carried him and you know i i maybe swept
it out of my swept it under the rug
under the radar out of my mind or
whatever but the one thing that just
popped to me was when i turned it back
on i just like even there that guy's
covered like glue perfect throw on the
money aggressive as hell good coverage
here boom perfect spot outside there are
so many throws in the bootleg and play
action game where he's running to the
right full speed and jarvis landry's
opened by three inches 25 yards down the
field he throws it and doesn't think
twice rips it in their perfect throw 30
yard completion a a tremendous deep ball
explosive arm thrower and he can change
momentum of the game with his right arm
and i think you know he cleaned up
mechanics last year he was a better
decision maker he was more mature on and
off the field like we talked about and
he had moments where i just went whoa i
mean that's big time throws big time
plays way to play that game baker
mayfield and and that's why he rose for
me and he is borderline top 10 top
10-ish type talent for sure
and you put him in the category of the
guy who can make chicken salad when the
play that's called falls apart right i
do he is one of the things i got written
down here you know tight window thrower
you know high degree difficulty the
other thing i wrote is not a great
runner but a great mover and a hopper oh
my gosh that's the other thing that he
pops out is here he is he's got a
bootleg oh man there's a free defense
end he makes the move to break the guy's
ankle and then throws the ball so it
might not be running but all you do you
can picture him right in the pocket he's
hopping around and then he's throwing
the ball like he's got an innate ability
to kind of see both and make it happen
not a great runner but a great mover is
what i would say about baker mayfield
that is a sneaky great week one game i
almost wish that it had been held for
later in the season browns and chiefs
right but man what what what a game
that's going to be
the the mayfield mahomes game from 2016
66-59 i think it was the final score
ridiculous numbers for both and i'm sure
mayfield wants to turn that
into a rivalry with mahomes and they've
got the team now to do it and mayfield's
the quarterback yeah to do it and you
know
hey 2019
regression
and and you see what happens when you
don't have good coaching it is
coaching's part of this you know you
made the point the footwork was sloppy
various things had had fallen off
just because you figured it out you
still have to have repetition you have
to be thinking about it you have
everything lined up just right or you
will
see yourself dip in relation to the guys
who are constantly buttoned up and
coached and told what to do and reminded
what to do and they go through that
process and it's easy to let your habits
slip yeah it is you got to stay on time
that's why we see brady rogers they're
they're always all over those type of
things it is you could take a month off
from football and not throw and you you
could lose some of those things if
somebody doesn't stay on top of you and
you you think you're doing it the right
way but then you know you go back and
watch film and go damn i'm not like i
gotta have somebody out here watching me
a little bit so all of that improved it
definitely did and yeah definitely one
of those candidates mike to your point
where this he could be the guy that
maybe challenges mahomes and the chiefs
and it becomes a rivalry let's not
forget too
like
baker mayfield was kind of moved out of
texas tech and cliff kingsbury because
mahomes was coming in that was part of
the reasons he transferred to oklahoma
you know they knew mahomes was coming i
think they were kind of like okay we
like you but they weren't sure how much
they liked them and they thought mahomes
are special and they're like all right
you can transfer so that would add to
the rivalry too in a cool kind of way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports